c'est parmi les mesures préconisées pour
lutter contre le terrorisme il ya la
levée du secret médical psychiatrique
pour les terroristes potentiels
la question fait débat c'est tout de
suite le pour et contre
entre claude moniquet président de l'es6
et michel gaida il est psychiatre et
expert judiciaire
[Musique]
il y à un empilement législatif en
france qui est terrifiant après chaque
incident on a une loi sur le terrorisme
depuis 1986 28 loi dont sept qui ont été
passés exclusivement depuis les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015
ça me semble beaucoup ça finit par être
confiante y retrouve pas maintenant sur
la question fondamentale le secret
médical nous concerne tous c'est notre
vie privée
c'est un droit humain d'être pour
consulter un médecin sans que personne
ne soit au courant
cela étant il existe déjà des
dérogations de secret médical sur les
violences faites les violences
conjugales
je pense sa part de ma part violence
pour enfants et en cas de risque
imminent pour la vie ou la sécurité soit
du patient sauf d'une autre personne
donc si on reste dans un cadre très
défini très strictes ou qui ne permet
pas de débordement de débordements moi
ça ne me choque pas qu'on envisage une
mesure qui permettent aux services de
sécurité aux services de renseignements
éventuellement les médecins qui sont
rattachés à ses services un peut-être
pour que le secret ne soit pas diffusée
partout de partager ces informations
ce débat d'un période récente n'est pas
nouveau puisque le ministre gérard
collomb l'avait déjà évoqué en 1900 2017
à l'occasion je pense des attentats à
l'étranger mais ce qui se profilait en
france et il y avait eu des réactions je
pense par exemple celle du dr marty qui
était président de l'union française
pour une médecine libre qui avait
indiqué mobiliser les psychiatres pour
dépister les terroristes de points quand
la bêtise le dispute à la lâcheté et
l'incompétence vous nous faites honte je
ne prends pas parti par ailleurs le
docteur ben gourion qui était psychiatre
libéral et ancien chef de clinique à
sainte-anne souligné dans une tribune
qui était parue dans le monde que le
lien entre
l'adie mentale et terrorisme n'est pas
avéré que la loi sur le secret médical
n'est pas compatible avec la mise en
place d'une collaboration entre
psychiatre et services de police et il
concluait et je partage que plutôt de
chercher des terroristes chez nos
patients en souffrance les responsables
politiques feraient mieux de nous aider
à battre en brèche les stéréotypes
stigmatisant et véhicule la société sur
la maladie mentale ce qui peut être
choquant par exemple c'est que j'entends
le ministre de l'intérieur dire qu'on
pourrait croiser le fichier est resté le
fichier des radicaliser avec que les
données des malades qui sont internés
par consentement donc décision
judiciaire là c'est choquant parce qu'on
est sur un phénomène de masse et je vois
mal qu'on puisse aller chercher des
milliers de gens en disant qu'ils sont
pas malades qui sont potentiellement des
terroristes
maintenant siens d'un cas précis si un
médecin suis une personne qui tient
régulièrement des propos extrêmement
virulent et de nature terroriste
à mon avis ça ne mérite pas un
signalement maintenant si le médecin
apprend que cette personne qui tient des
propos terroristes à acheter des armes
ou s'est procuré des armes
on est dans un autre cas de figure on
met dans un cas de figure effectivement
il peut y avoir un danger grave et
imminent pour le meuble pour le malade
et pour d'autres personnes
et là je pense que ça nécessiterait ça
justifierait en tout cas la levée du
secret médical
mais je pense que c'est le médecin qui
doit décider et pas l'autorité publique
le secret médical et déjà non opposables
aux professionnels de la santé ou de
l'action sociale qui a form le préfet et
à paris le préfet de police du caractère
dangereux pour elle même ou pour autrui
des personnes qui les consultent et dont
ils savent qu'elles détiennent une arme
ou qu'elles ont manifesté leur intention
d'acquérir une donc je vois pas ce
qu'une loi supplémentaire ajoutera si on
regarde le nombre de malades
psychiatriques qui sont dangereux il y
en a finalement très peu donc là on
risque de s'engouffrer dans une
situation qui risque d'être
préjudiciable à l'ensemble de la
population qui
à plus ou moins à des difficultés
psychologiques et on sait que cette part
de la population est importante à des
degrés divers et la levée du secret dans
des lots caractère stigmatisant de des
troubles psychologiques que les troubles
mentaux sera sans doute une catastrophe
dans ce cas là nous sommes dans une
situation dans laquelle on montrer qu'on
fait quelque chose il faut absolument
passer une loi
je pense que le corps législatif actuel
suffit à cette question de lever
potentiel et sur dérogation du secret
médical et qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
d'aller plus loin mais je ne veux dire
je crains je suis certain que dans les
semaines et les mois à venir
cette question va être une question une
des questions centrales du débat sur la
sécurité
et c'est évidemment regrettable parce
qu'on va au risque de prendre des
décisions de manière hâtive et dans une
vision électoraliste et populiste au
lieu de prendre le temps de réfléchir et
de se dire qu'en définitive les cirques
ont donné des conditions qui existent
déjà sont suffisantes
je pense qu'effectivement il ya une
façon de légiférer qui est qui et qui
il n'est peut-être pas satisfaisant de
réagir à l'émotion les centaines édité
en gonflant les textes réglementaires et
législatifs
on voit que des lois anciennes ont
perduré longtemps parce qu'ils étaient
lus mûrement réfléchi pendant des années
maintenant ce n'est plus le cas je pense
que la question du secret médical et les
talonnent de tous les autres secrets et
cette transparence est effrayante car
elle préfigure de façon anticipée le
monde de rouelles dans 1984
c'est à dire le fait qu'on devient sens
sans ombre lumière mais avec une
apparence extérieure qui se situent
uniquement sur le plan de la
représentation sociale